this is a friendly environment I came
backstage you seemed physically
intimidated by me yeah I know you bout
six photo I had to make sure I was ready
yeah I came into the room and you
realized once again how big I am and how
powerful and I saw fear in your eyes
I've come to here for no play play no
games all right
you know it's funny I was think about
this today you a media day Superbowl
this this this last Superbowl everyone
asking you questions and you just keep
saying over and over again I'm just here
so I won't get fined you've had issues
getting fined I wanted to assure you
nothing you do will earn you a fine here
tonight you are in a safe zone is this a
safe place for something like that so I
came today with a shirt
thank you you can find a lot you've been
find a lot for we have a shot of it
grabbing your crotch that looks like a
ballet move right there I used to get
him here in the early days after I tell
a really funny joke I jump up in the air
and grab my crotch NBC at the time I was
like you can't do that but you have
shown the way you have shown the way for
how all of us should act and just trying
to put it out there man I don't got them
in a lot of trouble for grabbing my
bathing yeah if you call it your ding
ding what ding ding yeah you probably
shouldn't use the phrase put it out
there yeah sometimes a guy's got to grab
his ding ding you think that's a line
that will never be repeated that's $500
right oh hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography